spacex has been around for over 18
years at this point during which time
they have been able to send people to
the iss
the land rockets vertically and are well
on their way to mars
on top of this they have been pretty
consistent at pulling in a few billion
per year
with projections placing them at two to
three billion dollars the last few years
moreover it's quite likely that the
market will bid up the stock
just because it's an elon musk company
despite this elon musk has been very
stubborn about keeping spacex private
at least in the meantime so why does
elon musk refuse to take spacex public
will spacex ever become public and what
are some options to invest in spacex
today
well starting off one of the biggest
concerns when taking a company public
is volatility and this is especially
true for companies with revolutionary
technology
whenever you're dealing with
revolutionary technology the company
is highly prone to market fluctuations
whenever the stock market is booming
we'll see many investors throwing money
at ai
and space companies but when the stock
market is hurting
the first place investors will take
money out of is such technology
as a result we'd likely see spacex stock
responding multiples to the overall
market
for instance if the s p 500 drops three
percent
spacex stock may drop 15 or 20 percent
which would make consistent fundraising
a nightmare
aside from this many investors will want
short-term gains
which would contradict and possibly
hinder spacex's long-term goals
for instance many short-term investors
looking to just
hold spacex for a couple of months or a
couple of years
may prefer that spacex focus on
expanding starlink
and making it more profitable as opposed
to syncing
all of their profits from starlink into
mars which is thus far
an unproven market going public would
also force spacex to devote a good
amount of their effort
into quarterly growth to keep investor
confidence high
with that being said elon musk basically
doesn't want to deal with tending to
short-term expectations
of the market but what about raising
money
wouldn't going public help raise money
and does make mars easier
well not really as spacex is already
valued quite highly
within the private venture capitalist
market as of august 2020
spacex is worth 46 billion dollars
which means that they are valued at
roughly 15 to 20 times
their projected annual revenue to put
this in perspective
if tesla was valued like spacex tesla
would be worth
up to 500 billion dollars which is a
full 100 billion higher than their
already sky high
400 billion valuation from a p e ratio
perspective
out of their two to three billion
dollars in revenue they could likely
profit a few hundred million
but of course with them investing so
heavily into starship
they're likely profiting less than a
hundred million if they're making money
in the first place
so their p e ratio if they are in fact
profitable
is likely in the several hundred range
if not well over a thousand
considering this spacex is already
valued
quite richly and it's not likely that
the public market
would treat them any better but even if
they did
it's not a big deal as spacex doesn't
need the money
currently spacex's biggest bottle cap to
growth
isn't capital but rather technological
improvement
you see the main reason tesla went
public
was because they didn't have a choice
making rockets
is really expensive but it's not even
close to the cost of mass producing
electric cars
aside from this many of the early
investors into tesla
were individuals like elon's brother who
likely preferred to eventually have an
exit plan from the company
conversely some of the largest investors
of spacex
include corporations like google bank of
america
fidelity and nasa considering that all
these companies
and organizations are worth hundreds of
billions if not trillions
they don't care to cash out anytime soon
moreover if all else fails we have elon
musk himself
in october of 2011 forbes estimated that
elon
musk was worth about 680 million dollars
meaning that he was only worth a few
hundred million dollars
during the ipo of tesla of course
that's a lot of money for an individual
but not that much for a multi-billion
dollar
corporation not to mention most of that
money
is tied up in stock thus elon musk
didn't have very much funding power
himself
in 2011. today however
elon musk is worth over 100 billion
and though virtually all of that is
still tied up in stock
he has much more flexibility today
selling 100 million dollars
of his 300 million stake in tesla in
is not a good image but selling 3
billion out of a 70 to 80 billion
tesla stick today is not a big deal
so elon could single-handedly fund five
billion dollars for spacex
on an annual basis for at least the next
couple of decades
similar to what jeff bezos has done with
blue origin
thus spacex really has no financial
concerns
at the moment nor well into the future
so they have no reason to go public for
financial reasons
with that being said will we ever see
spacex go public
well fortunately yeah most likely
spacex is already nearly a 50 billion
company and well past the prospect of an
acquisition
and these prospects are basically going
to zero percent
as spacex grows into the hundreds of
billions
as a result the only way to relate cash
out of spacex at this point
is by going public sure maybe elon will
hold
till his debt but i'm sure that most of
the other investors
do eventually want to cash out and elon
is very much open to this idea his main
fear isn't really going public but
rather
going public before the mars transport
system is in place
by that point the vast majority of
investors will have no issues with
heavily investing into mars
as mars is a reality at that point as
opposed to simply a dream
moreover spacex will no doubt have much
stronger financials by then
giving them much more stability than if
they were going public today
spacex is still planning on getting
people to mars
in 2024 so we might see a spacex ipo
near the end of this decade but if not
definitely in the 2030s so unfortunately
though it's likely that a spacex ipo
will eventually happen
it's still quite a whiles out however
there
are some options to get some money into
spacex today
the easiest way to invest in spacex
today
would be to pour some money into some of
spacex's investors
google does hold upwards of 10 percent
of spacex
but this is just a sliver of the google
empire
thus for every thousand dollars you
invest into google
approximately five dollars goes to
spacex so
only half a percent but google is a
pretty solid company to invest in
so that is something to consider if you
would like to get a bigger chunk however
a great option may be buying etfs that
include spacex
etfs or exchange traded funds are just
portfolios of stock
these can be made up of just public or
private companies
or a combination of both but anyways
some of these funds have a stake in
spacex such as this one from fidelity
most of these guys only have a decimal
level stake in spacex
but you may be able to find one with a
couple of percent
also as spacex continues to grow it's
likely that these funds will increase
their stakes in the company
another positive with etfs is that they
generally invest
all the funds money into the same niche
so though maybe only 0.5 of your money
will go to spacex
the other portion will go to companies
like blue origin
boeing and virgin galactic as a result
etfs are a phenomenal way to bet on an
entire industry
as opposed to just one company and i
think this is probably the best choice
for most retail investors but a more
direct method to invest in spacex
would be through platforms such as
equity zen and forged global
these companies specialize in making
private companies like spacex
more accessible to the average retail
investor to achieve this
they find insiders and or venture
capitalists with investments in the
company
to sell a portion of their stake at a
certain price
and this is what is accessible for you
and me to buy
so by using such platforms you can
directly invest in private companies
but there are some things to consider
and some limitations
first of all the insiders who are
selling will no doubt be selling at a
decently higher price
than what they got in for so you will
almost certainly be investing at a
premium
but you are getting in before they go
public so that
could be worth it something else to
consider is that when buying and selling
you don't know how long you'll have to
wait it could be tomorrow
but it might also be three months from
now and finally
the last major hurdle when using such
programs
is that many of them have minimum
investment requirements
and you likely also have to be an
accredited investor
which basically means that you need to
have at least a million dollars
in other investments so if you meet
these requirements and are fine with
short-term illiquidity
these programs may be exactly what
you're looking for
but anyways that's just a couple of ways
you can get a piece
of the space game would you guys invest
in spacex
comment that down below also if you guys
found this explanation helpful
then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one